we have a secret project happening at
corridor digital closing the dark it all
starts at the source underneath the
stairs where the water lives here we
find over half the ingredients for one
of my most famous dishes
Sam's bachelor party bouton noodles soup
all right okay this is a recipe that
I've been making for a long time
basically it's an la thing because it
requires a good Japanese grocery store
to be nearby
you need some special ingredients but
this is how I make it
screw the experts don't listen to him we
are out in the desert for Nico's
bachelor party last year and it's a big
hit because it's not the type of dish
you expect to have in the middle of a
campsite in the middle of a desert
but because some of the ingredients kind
of come frozen you can bring them out to
the desert two or three days can pass
and then they you know it takes a while
for them to thaw and then you can make
it fresh so it kind of all works out the
only problem it needs a lot of water so
you have to have a huge jug of water
along with you to make the broth what is
Odonis these thick thick rice noodles I
got him right here check it out right
here frozen food on noodles is nice nice
and thick and plum first off okay
remember okay
country go I got channel combat ship so
he said a couple things right at the
beginning of the story and that's it uh
that dude on little soup it all starts
with the broth
it's all about making up and whipping up
fine broth
don't forget to clean your tub your
noodle tub out here in the desert things
can get pretty dusty scrub the tub
getting those grits out rough this water
with seasoning first off stove I got to
turn the gas on
alright here we go
do the thing the tap water in LA he
stinks so I'm using this boot on little
soup
Sam style starts with noodles thin slice
the pork belly and then as a garnish
we have green onions here's the secret
ingredients though first secret
ingredient this stuff you can't read
then me neither
back in the day I was like alright how
do we make good food on soup like what
the heck I go to a Japanese grocery
store I stay in a horrible wall foreign
characters and bottles that I cannot
read and I was like God darn so what I
did is I used the internet and I took a
photo of it and I sent it out on Twitter
and I said hey anyone who can read this
wall what do I need to make noodle soup
and one person in particular responded
Joe Moore Yama he was like hey I know
the good suit bases so he circles a
bunch of the things on the photo I
upload it and sends it right back to me
this was one of the first ones I tried
and it was perfect I can't read a single
thing on it but this is soup face and
it's kinda like a boolean you know for
like raw the whole that's really in here
is soy sauce dried fish flakes bunch of
seasoning etc etc this is the poor
foundation that we did that we don
noodle soup there's plenty of other
brands that make this that some even
have English labels so one part base
three parts and water you don't want it
too salty this stuff has a ton of
Solomon
but I feel like that's a good place to
start the water is taking on a lot of
the color already it smells good because
here's the thing new Dom noodle soup has
a really thin base technically it's
usually a very light but I once again I
like to make my broth
Hardy so let's do that next up we have
the second foundation of our flavor
since like pork belly the fat will
render in the boiling water and will
make the broth thick and rich and tasty
flavorful plus they'll be pork pieces
leftover for people to get a little
protein you can get beef beef works too
but I like pork because it uh it renders
a little more cleanly than beef nice
anyway like humans she's more like omens
secret ingredient number two and this
comes at the broth stage and it comes
afterwards a little too Japanese rice
seasoning it's like seaweed some sesame
salt a little pepper
this one has bonito flakes in it which
is kind of the core foundation flavor of
Bhutan and most like Japanese broth so
basically within this container are the
staples of Japanese seasoning a little
bit in there just like that boom and now
we wait
basically I'm gonna wait for it to start
boiling and let it boil for about five
minutes get the water hot at the pork
hock fully cooked
get the meat rendering make the broth
nice thick rich and hearty and then we
put the noodle school son just another
jank dobby strikes again there's no
better time than standing in a puddle of
jank to tell you guys about the next
limited edition tea that's coming out
this is the first time anyone's hearing
of this we are doing a limited edition
dobby tea Sam went out and contacted an
artist and he got an artist's rendering
of the elusive Dobby the god of jank
we've captured and put on a t-shirt
remember the Dobby shirt is on sale for
10 days and 10 days only we also put it
on this ax right here which I love hats
I wear them every day go on and get that
into them speaking of hats we really
released something the original black
and yellow Corda digital snapback hat we
released this it's available now we also
did something else for you
just in time for fall a cozy crewneck
sweatshirt man this thing is so
comfortable give it to your girlfriend
give it to your boyfriend whatever it's
great then we added this also amazing
this shirt is so comfortable I guarantee
you'll fall asleep and die in it that's
how you notice we released this shirt as
well not just because it's an awesome
shirt but also because this shirt closed
in the dark that's right you see
corridor
you see digital and you see the crazy
skeleton dude coming up over the
mountains so anyway all these are
available you guys are interested go on
and check them out remember the Dobie
T's on sale for 10 days only quarter
digital dot-com slash store night has
fallen I skip a broth good soup 60%
broth I'm gonna taste my broth here I'm
not gonna lie couple things gonna happen
here first off didn't get enough soup
base so I had to put a little soy sauce
in to salt it back up the other problem
is that since I can't read Japanese or
English I bought the wrong rice
seasoning and it's got sugar added into
it for a sweet kick that does not go
well with bouton soup so people have to
put that on at the end at their own
discretion all right
I'm gonna chug this right now okay yeah
there we go it's got a little bit that
like fish edge to it but it's got that
Hardy pork base a little salt a little
soy perfect that'll do
all right let's put the noodles in they
come frozen but they quickly unfreeze
when you put them in here the key is to
not overcook them just like Italian
pasta it's all about finding that al
dente spot all right you don't want your
noodles to be all mushy and gross yes
slippery and sloppy you want them to
have a little bit a little bit of bite
them okay we are going to cook these up
we're gonna boil them once they are
completely loose and softened up I'm
only gonna let them boil for like
another minute to cut the heat and
surfing right away these either another
knot the ends
I don't want either end I don't want
these gross slimy pieces on the outside
either great you don't the slime or just
look at these little Slimers the Slimers
on the outside delicious media you
probably like eating wilted lettuce too
slimy this this little slimy
then these outer parts these outer parts
have already started decomposing which
is why they're slippery delicious not
delicious they are decaying this is
decaying matter just like sure that of
it oh my god you're nihilist sorry more
decaying matter we've tried to chop
these as finely as I possibly can not
bad we got the money in that's enough
cooking this this this is garnish you
don't cook green onions green onions are
meant to be eaten raw you cooked them
what do they become the king of matter
oh this is taking about like 17 million
years the thing well the noodles aren't
frozen anymore what's the Japanese word
for al dente that's what I wanted well
if I knew it I'd say it's good that
noodles are done
last year at the top of the
hey man hey welcome to JJ's solutions
firm what started as a simple project to
redo the sound lounge has evolved into
JJ's consultancy where we don't have
problems we have opportunities for
solutions really we've been in business
about two days and I gotta say things
are going fantastic we have a secret
project happening at corridor digital
via JJ's consulting firm the secret
project codename is operation JJ that's
also my son's name but that's the beauty
of it makes it easy to remember yeah it
makes it easy for me to remember if you
guys subscribe you're gonna see Jared
and I and Sam build something in this
room come the end of the month maybe
early November TBD but we're gonna be
announcing something big for 2019 for
corridor digital when we got this space
the guy that lived here previous to us
that lived here for 20 years and the way
that he used to make his rent in the
late 90s was by throwing raves in this
warehouse when we moved in the entire
studio was running off of 212 amp
breakers
there was a fish pond right there you
can still see remnants of it he called
himself an artist okay he had like weird
paintings hanging from the ceiling that
were the size of the wall and he had
like it there's a motorcycling over
there and he had a waterfall and there
was a
calm down right here and then if there
was a waterfall right here and then
everything underneath the stairs was a
koi pond see this is where he drilled in
the foundation of the koi pond so he had
a koi pond and then this whole thing was
a koi pond it's all pretty and gross and
janky when we moved in and he was like
you guys want it
we're like we'll take it and then we put
a bunch of money into it to make it what
are this today he'd built these units he
built all the units in the building it
was a paint powder factory you know when
you go to Home Depot you buy the base
paint which is just white and then they
put the color into it that's paint
powder in each of the units there's this
mezzanine
well this mezzanine runs the full length
of this side of the building because
this the other side was the office and
this was the production floor so if you
go over to that studio studio five and
six you can still see the yellow and
pink and blue powder stains on the
concrete so they guys in here redid this
studio and so you can see the mezzanine
keeps going this is where they had the
mixers do you look up there oh yeah
that's the hoist to move the giant
mixers around the stains the color
stains it's not a murder site it's not a
murder site now and this which is now
node was the blast room or the testing
room which is why it has this door here
and so they used to test paint in this
room some things change some things
never do boys what are we gonna serve it
in
whoa anyone nudes but guys I hope you
like guru broth there we go there we go
decoration there you go Buddhist hot -
chuckling is this freaking steam is
burning me yes you mean give me say how
a garnish if the shower is just so right
Lucy was it like that dude it's so good
oh oh
Thank You Stan oh my gosh dude how'd you
do it a little nervous Janet be good
okay his roles pretty good
it's a good lunch turn it well I love
baking food for people is one of the
most fun things in the world is very
rewarding and flavorful there's no
better feeling then seeing people not
throw up when they eat your recipes
[Music]